an attempt to defuse tensions between
London and Tehran over this Iranian
tanker Jeremy Hunt has told around
Foreign Minister the ship could soon be
released from Gibraltar our concern has
always been the destination of the
tanker and the fact that it was taking
oil to Syria not the origin of the oil
and I said that if we could receive
sufficient guarantees that that tanker
was not headed for Syria then we would
be able to resolve the situation
following of course due process in the
Gibraltar courts
Royal Marines helped the Gibraltar
authorities to detain the grace one
super tanker last week it's suspected of
trying to breach EU sanctions on Syria
the captain and three crew members were
arrested and released on bail without
charge
the territory's Chief Minister said to
brother is determined to enforce
sanctions linked to Syria through the
courts but he said we would be prepared
to facilitate the release of the
detained asset to a rightful claimant if
we were satisfied we had received
guarantees it would not be going to
Syria or to any entity sanctioned under
the relevant EU regulations the seizure
of the ship triggered fury in Tehran and
threats of retaliation against Britain
in the Gulf
this world Navy warship was forced to
protect a tanker from Iranian gunboats
and the heightened threat prompted
Britain to send a second major warship
to the region but even with HMS Duncan
enroute the UK's desire is for peace
what Britain successfully managed to do
is to combine a robust approach a hard
power approach with a single ship is you
know wills nothing too dramatic and
nothing drastic it was a single Royal
Navy vessel and it managed to foresee
her engines to back down and managed to
make them talk Britain's call for calm
is in contrast with the United States it
wants to build a coalition of warships
and planes to escort tankers through the
Gulf that will be seen by Tehran as a
new escalation not as a way to avert
conflict
Deborah Haynes Sky News